[Background Conversations]
Henry: Most governments deal with [inaudible]
and many of them are not organized to deal
with the long range and perhaps more important
problems.
The most useful thing a group like this in
Davos can do, since they are not here in their
official copacioty is to focus on the long
range questions.
And to make sure that we don't just deal with
the crisis which are the symptoms of the fact
that we haven't solved the problems of the
future.
And make sure that in future Davos meetings
there are fewer crisis and more of the punitive
and long range thinking.
>> As Mr. Kissinger, we're from writers [inaudible]
Kissinger [Inaudible]
>> Just a quick, just a quick question about
this, the Davos question, how important